l'échec de la conférence de l'opep à
genève le marché pétrolier international
en ébullition italie cinq ans après
l'enlèvement et l'assassinât d'aldo moro
verdict maximale pour une trentaine de
terroristes reprise des négociations
israélo libanaise à khaldé yasser arafat
réaffirma antennes de la transit jans de
l'ol paie la retraite
à 26 ans bjorn borg renonce au tennis
professionnel
madame monsieur bonsoir depuis plus de
neuf ans leur union sacrée sur l'autel
de l'or noir ébranlait l'économie des
pays industrialisés et rendait un peu
plus exemple les pays en voie de
développement
aujourd'hui après plusieurs crises déjà
ni à des tensions politiques locales et
aussi à l'évolution du marché de
l'énergie
aujourd'hui donc le peps vinci à son
tour les pays exportateurs de pétrole
membre de l'organisation n'ont en effet
réussi à se mettre d'accord sur rien ni
sur le prix ni sur les quantités de
pétrole souhaitable pour maintenir à la
fois leur niveau de ressources
individuelles et un prix de référence
commun sur le marché international de
nouveaux clivages se sont fait jour et
selon l'expression même du ministre
saoudien du pétrole l'avenir à court
terme du marché des produits pétroliers
n'est pas brillant ce qui paradoxalement
n'est pas non plus une bonne nouvelle
pour les pays consommateurs de pétrole
alors voyons d'abord ce qui s'est passé
aujourd'hui à genève philippe sassier
oui on vient juste d'avoir laurent sorin
qui couvrait pour antenne de cette
réunion de l'opep et ce matin il me
disait qu'un accord était en vue qu'un
accord était possible en effet les 13
pays membres de l'opep s'étaient
entendus semble-t-il pour diminuer leur
production de pétrole en 1983 l'a
diminué de 1 million de barils par jour
c'est-à-dire faire en sorte qu'elles
atteignent 17 million et demi de barils
par jour tous les pays étaient d'accord
pour baisser leurs propres productions y
compris l'arabie saudite qui jusqu'à
présent s'était toujours opposé à cette
diminution de production et puis tout a
capoté sur un problème de prix celui ci
est dû
d'abord il suffisait il s'agissait de
bien marquer la différence entre les
différentes types de pétrole c'est un
petit peu comme les vins le pétrole il
ya les grands crus d'un côté puis il ya
le gros rouge de l'autre il ya donc des
différences de prix quand on marque deux
content de marquer les pays producteurs
et puis il s'agissait également de
régler ce problème de diminutions de
tarifs que pratiquent actuellement les
pays afin de mieux écouler leur
production et bien c'est sur ce problème
des prix que l'on ne s'est pas entendu
et c'est ce qui explique cet échec de la
conférence de l'opep et alors là c'est
donc un clivage entre pays africains et
pays du golfe
vingt pays africains de côté pays du
golfe de l'autre mais l'échec de genève
a bien sûr pesé sur l'évolution du
marché pétrolier il va effectivement
peser sur l'évolution du marché
pétrolier on va probablement le sentir à
première vue tout le monde peut se
réjouir d'une zizanie au sein de
l'association des producteurs de pétrole
dont l'explosion des prix il ya dix ans
est restée sur l'estomac des pays
industriels en effet que va-t-il se
passer à la suite de cet échec est plus
grave que prévu parce que actuellement
le monde entier regorge de pétrole on va
probablement assister à une guerre des
tarifs qui a déjà commencé et par
conséquent à une nouvelle baisse des
prix celle-ci sera d'autant plus
sensible à la proche du printemps
lorsqu'on aura besoin de moins de fuel
pour se chauffer on peut donc s'attendre
si le dollar de flambe pas trop à des
baisses de carburant dans les mois qui
viennent pour la france il ne faut pas
oublier que nous sommes quand même liés
par des contrats à long terme
il ne faut pas non plus pour autant
sauter de joie car cette satisfaction et
médias ne doit pas dissimuler des
problèmes beaucoup plus graves
d'abord la baisse des prix du pétrole
peut accentuer les dissensions
politiques au moyen-orient et causé à
certains pays comme le koweït en
particulier les difficultés aux
conséquences imprévisibles
ensuite les pays producteurs de pétrole
qui se sont endettés auront beaucoup de
peine à rembourser leurs dettes et ce
sera le cas notamment de l'indonésie et
du mexique enfin la baisse des prix du
pétrole peut déclencher un certain
désordre international notamment ceux
qui concernent les monnaies déjà
aujourd'hui l'échec de la conférence de
l'opep a immédiatement provoqué une
chute brutale de la livre anglaise qui
est tombée par rapport au dollar à son
plus bas niveau depuis 1976 pour un pays
comme la grande bretagne qui compte sur
le pétrole de la mer du nord pour
trouver solution à ses problèmes de
financement
l'échec de la conférence de l'opep
signifie que l'état disposera de moins
d'argent
et puis dans d'autres pays certains ces
investissements concernant des énergies
de substitution au pétrole comme le
charbon par exemple peuvent être remis
en cour si une stabilisation des prix du
pétrole était une condition nécessaire à
une amélioration de la situation
économique en occident
le désordre qui risquent de s'instaurer
nous fait courir un danger qu'il ne faut
pas sous-estimer le ministre français
des relations extérieures claude
cheysson a estimé fort regrettable
l'échec de cette conférence un échec
at-il dit qu'ils n'aient al'avantage de
personnes il a dit à bruxelles où les
ministres des affaires étrangères des
dix ont une fois plus sans résultat
examiner le problème de la contribution
britannique au budget européen
un mois encore du marché des changes le
dollar a gagné sur toutes les places
financières à commencer par paris où il
a franchi à nouveau la barre des 7
francs en gagnant un peu moins de 2 % en
une seule séance
les dirigeants socialistes européens
face à la crise internationale
après leur rencontre hier dans le cadre
du colloque sur le changement organisé
par le parti socialiste français
les six chefs de gouvernement ont décidé
de revenir à paris en mai prochain
c'est ce qu'a annoncé aujourd'hui leur
homologue français le premier ministre
pierre mauroy
le but de cette nouvelle rencontre
adopter un plan de relance mondial et
concertée entre dirigeants socialistes
avant le prochain sommet des pays les
plus industrialisés du monde qui doit se
tenir en mai aux états unis
m
ouais
la scène politique française s'animer
s'échauffent à quelques 40 jours des
élections municipales
les réactions au congrès du rpr hier et
aussi la teneur de ce congrès le
durcissement du parti socialiste lui
même et de son allié communiste
hier aussi par la voix de georges
marchais autant de preuves albert du
rock que le débat politique français est
en train de changer de nature
oui depuis le feu d'artifice des
déclarations du week end
on voit clairement maintenant les trois
terrains essentiels de ce débat
politique
le premier est celui de la politique à
mener face à la crise pour la première
fois depuis sa défaite de 1981
l'opposition ne se contente plus de
critiquer le gouvernement mais présente
un contre programme c'est le plan de
redressement d'inspiration ultra
libérale du rpr jacques chirac ainsi
grillé valéry giscard d'estaing qui
regrettait encore il ya dix jours le
vide des propositions de l'opposition
du coup piqué au vif le gouvernement
socialiste est décidé à défendre son
action a vanté son bilan a expliqué ses
choix
une explication qu'il faut bien le dire
laissait à désirer depuis de nombreux
mois le deuxième terrain du débat est
celui du fonctionnement des institutions
cette fois c'est giscard qui a pris
l'initiative en parlant d'élections
législatives anticipées
depuis avant même que les électeurs ne
se soit prononcée la droite parle comme
si l'assemblée nationale actuelle les
têtes automatiquement condamnée en cas
d'échec de la gauche aux municipales
or s'il est évident qu'un gouvernement
doit toujours tenir compte des
avertissements donnés par les électeurs
il n'y a pas d'exemple d'un scrutin
local qui est entraîné une crise
nationale
les institutions ni résisterez
d'ailleurs pas puisqu'il ya un scrutin
tous les ans le président de la
république est le garant de ses
institutions
le 2 janvier sur antenne 2 ils
affichaient l'intention
devant la gravité de la crise mondiale
de restituer son harmonie au corps
social français
le moins qu'on puisse dire est que le
climat actuel ne se prête guère à
l'harmonie mais le chef de l'état pense
sans doute que le débat s'apaisera
quelques semaines après les municipales
et que la recherche d'un consensus
redeviendra alors possible
le troisième terrain enfin il ne faut
quand même pas l'oublier c'est le débat
municipal propre
mendient dans chaque ville les problèmes
de chaque ville mais il ne s'agit
évidemment pas seulement de caurel de
clocher on retrouvera d'ailleurs sur ce
terrain là mais à dimension humaine tous
les problèmes nationaux essentiel dans
notre dernier journal à 22h55 deux
journaliste et polémiste de choc
philippe alexandre de rtl et michel
cardoze de france inter débattront de ce
changement de temps imprimer à notre vie
politique
mais revenons dans l'immédiat aux
élections municipales est un l'un de ces
enjeux dont parlait à l'instant albert
du roy enjeu national et en même temps
local ainsi à cherbourg
la question du nucléaire domine déjà la
campagne électorale patrick esther
cherbourg célèbre dans le monde entier
parce qu'on n'y a tourné le fameux film
les parapluies de cherbourg les plus
connus aujourd'hui pour ces
manifestations antinucléaires c'est en
effet par ce port que transiter
combustible irradié étrangers qui
doivent être retraités à l'usiné de la
hague tout proche
aujourd'hui on casse ce terminal ou
accosté avant la guerre les paquebots de
luxe cherbourg comptait alors 43 mille
habitants aujourd'hui la vie économique
qui peu à peu le nord cotentin
il n'ya plus que 28 mille cherbourgeois
sur cette population
cinq mille personnes au moins travail
dans le seul secteur en pleine expansion
le nucléaire nucléaire civil comme ici
les cars assurant la liaison entre
cherbourg et l' usine de la hague
nucléaire civil encore avec le
gigantesque chantier de la centrale de
flamanville deux fois 13 100 mégawatts
les réacteurs atomiques les plus
modernes du monde
nucléaire militaire enfin avec l'arsenal
où sont assemblés les sous marins
nucléaires de la force de frappe
française se nucléaire qu'il soit civil
ou militaire va peser très lourd sur le
choix des électeurs pour les prochaines
élections municipales
moi je suis pour à 100 % ça donne du
travail à je crois à l'heure actuelle
3000 employés
peut-être 4000 si peu de temps dont je
suis quoi ressemble ce sens ce rapport
du travail
enfin c'est un danger hommes du
nucléaire dans le cotentin vont
influencer votre vote
certainement
et je vous dis pas dans ce sens jean
voir représente la liste de droite
des sondages donnent favori sa position
sur le nucléaire est sans ambiguïté j'ai
été pro-nucléaire parce que je pensais
que la france devait obtenir son
indépendance énergétique
cela ne signifie pas qu'il faille jeter
l'anathème contre les anti nucléaires et
surtout cela ne permettait pas pour des
raisons purement électoralistes de les
tromper odieusement comme ils ont été
trompés par le parti socialiste pour
rappeler cet aprèm premier visé par
cette attaque
le maire socialiste sortant jean pierre
godefroy qui promettait hier l'arrêt de
l'extension de l'usiné de la hague et
qui a bien changé d'avis il ya débat au
parlement
l'initiative du gouvernement se débat
abouti à l'extension de la hague au
respect des contrats avec l'étranger et
pour ce qui concerne le maire de
cherbourg il est en plein accord avec la
politique gouvernementale
élaboré dans ce débat parlementaire
si jean richard ely conseiller municipal
dissidents du parti socialiste se
présente lui contre les partisans du
nucléaire c'est surtout pour des raisons
économiques cette fois festive que le
nucléaire et les grands chantiers sont
de la poudre aux yeux et que avec ses
grands chantiers on a perdu 15 ans
d'aménagement du territoire car pendant
ce temps là notre tissu industriel
s'effiloche et lorsque les grands
chantiers sont terminés
ce sera le désert industriel dans notre
région et je crois que il faut faire
renaître le nord cotentin les forces
vives le kiffe les jeunes quittent le
nord cotentin et le les grands chantiers
ne sont pas du tout positif à ce niveau
là
pour les écologistes le nucléaire n'est
de toute façon pas positif du tout ici à
cherbourg les écologistes représentent
régulièrement 10% des voix des électeurs
un poids qui va être décisif cette fois
grâce au scrutin proportionnel
ils peuvent avoir les membres eux mêmes
et je crois que jusqu'à présent
n'étaient effectivement un groupe de
pression où cette fois ci on a toutes
les chances d'être élu les gens
attendent qu effectivement prennent
notre place et on participe à la vie
municipale à la gestion municipale
on a notre mot à dire on a des choses à
dire les écologistes ont malgré tout
fort à faire pour être écoutés au sein
du conseil municipal
en effet que ce soit les candidats de
gauche ou de droite qui l'emportent
ce seront de toute façon des partisans
du nucléaire le président mitterrand a
reçu aujourd'hui à l'elysée les
représentants des huit organisations
humanitaires de plus en plus préoccupés
par la pauvreté en france ces nouveaux
pauvres plus d'un million et demi de
ménages dont les revenus assure à peine
la survie sous l'effet de la crise
économique
le conseil des ministres de mercredi
prochain adoptera un plan de lutte
contre la grande pauvreté
sur les deux millions de chômeurs en
france plus d'un million en moins de 25
ans et près de la moitié d'entre eux
n'ont aucune formation professionnelle
la fédération de l'éducation nationale
qui a été reçu aujourd'hui par le
premier ministre propose un plan
d'urgence pour la formation
professionnelle des jeunes de 14 à 16
ans monsieur mauroy s'est déclaré
globalement d'accord il existe une base
d'accord possibles sur le régime des
retraites complémentaires à 60 ans c'est
l'avis du ministre des affaires sociales
pierre bérégovoy qui a reçu aujourd'hui
les représentants des syndicats et du
patronat
pour ceux qui souhaitent donc prendre
leur retraite à 60 ans pour que cela est
une rune pension comparable à celle
qu'ils auraient à 65 ans on
s'orienterait vers un système provisoire
de financement basé au départ sur un
emprunt garanti par l'état une nouvelle
réunion entre les partenaires sociaux
aura lieu mercredi
le conflit dans le secteur automobile
vous le savez cinq usines de la région
parisienne sont touchés à commencer par
celle de
nos flins ou aux huiles des dix huit
mille salariés ont entamé leur troisième
semaine de chômage technique à la suite
d'une grève la direction de renault a
annoncé aujourd'hui qu'elle est prête à
entamer des discussions globales
donc au niveau de l'ensemble de la régie
sur le site les problèmes spécifiques
les plus urgents tels qu'ils ressortent
des conflits actuels
par ailleurs la cgt la cfdt de flins
appelt ensemble les travailleurs en
chômage technique à se présenter
mercredi après midi à l'usiné pour
protester contre le lock out la régie
vient aussi de rappeler à l' usine cent
mille voitures défectueuses des r18
turbo diesel et des feux doté x dont les
circuits de freinage apparemment on
posait des problèmes
il s'agit de voitures construites avant
le 31 décembre 80 si vous en êtes
propriétaire vous devez recevoir par
lettre recommandée un avis de la régie
pour la retourner au garage
l'union fédérale des consommateurs et le
mouvement de défense des automobilistes
autodéfense avait déjà demandé le rappel
à la double isc c'est l'union fédérale
des consommateurs en effet qui alerté
par ses adhérents découvre en mars 1982
les anomalies de freinage sur certains
véhicules construits rappelons le avant
le 31 décembre 1981
l'organisation de consommateurs déclare
alors je cite
devant la gravité des conséquences
plusieurs accidents corporels étant
survenu nous avons demandé à rencontrer
la direction de la régie renault
quand nous avons constitué un dossier
qui venait pas plus accablant nous avons
demandé à la régie renault liverpool
recevoir pour qu'on discute ensemble du
problème et la régie renault pour
souligner comme le attitude très
positive de la régie a reconnu
effectivement qu'il y avait une
difficulté sérieuse sur ces véhicules et
nous a fait part de son intention dès le
22 décembre de procéder à un rappel ce
qui est quand même une première en
france c'est la première fois qu'on voit
un industriel jouer vraiment le jeu que
les consommateurs aient procédé à un
rappel volontaire d'un véhicule
la régie renault cherche à dédramatiser
la fait le dialogue avec les
organisations de consommateurs lui
paraît être la meilleure solution
elle ne nie pas les fêtes et accepte de
répondre à cette question que
reproche-t-on à ces véhicules
on leur reproche d'avoir dans certains
cas tout à fait exceptionnel à d'autres
condamnations en italie où la peine de
mort n'existe pas la cour d'assises de
rome a décidé aujourd'hui de très
lourdes peines pour la quarantaine de
terroristes accusés d'avoir organisé ou
d'avoir participé directement à
l'enlèvement et à l'assassinât d'aldo
moro
cinq ans après le calvaire du président
de la démocratie chrétienne italienne
qui vous vous en souvenez avait été
séquestré pendant 55 jours avant d'être
exécutées par ses geôliers la fin de ce
procès signifie en italie les pilotes
d'un véritable drame national
même si plusieurs zones d ombres n'ont
pas été éclaircies de rome victor
vraiment leur procès est terminé
les assassins d'aldo moro retourne en
prison pour la vie dans un grand
déploiement de forces de police c'est la
dernière fois que les terroristes
traversera ma voiture alors qu'ils l'ont
fait tous les jours pendant près de dix
mois
c'est que le procès moreau a duré plus
de neuf mois dans un palais des sports
transformé en tribunal protégé et
surveillé jour et nuit
les jurés ont délibéré pendant une
semaine avant de prononcer leur verdict
le verdict le voici aux nanas 4 cuil 32
condamnations à la prison à vie alors
qu'on jugeait 63 terroristes les plus
grands noms les vedettes du terrorisme
italien elles ont été condamnées au
maximum des peines prévues pour
l'enlèvement et l'assassinât d'aldo moro
mais aussi pour onze meurtres politiques
commises à rome entre 1978 et 1981 sans
compter les tentatives de meurtres et
les attentes en tout genre on peut citer
les noms de prospero gallinari l'homme
qui a exécuté aldo moro 7 mario morisi
l'organisateur de l'enlèvement d'aldo
moro valérie morucci ou encore de viana
femme barbara ou de nathalie à l'igas
indifférence voulu provocante à la
lecture du verdict
ce qu'il faut noter c'est que les
terroristes dit repentis qui ont
collaboré avec la justice comme anton ça
va ou emilia libera ont été condamnés
cassez en prison
la loi qui prévoit des réductions de
peine pour les repentis a été très
efficace
on l'a bien vu au cours de ce procès
les confessions fleuve d'anthony sa
vaste ont permis d'arrêter une centaine
de terroristes
c'est plus qu'un procès qui vient de se
terminer c'est toute la période du
terrorisme triomphant qui risque d'être
fatal à l'italie est ce que cela veut
dire que le terrorisme est
définitivement démantelé constatant tout
simplement une chose c'est que depuis
l'ouverture de ce procès il y a dix mois
il ya eu davantage d'arrestation que
d'attentats je dirais même plus
il n'y a pas eu d'attentât important
depuis près d'un an en italie
au proche orient neuvième séance
aujourd'hui des négociations israélo
libanaise parrainées par les états unis
à khaldé au liban le tir d'une roquette
tout près de l'hôtel où se tenait les
pourparlers a quelque peu tendu
l'atmosphère ce matin un militaire
israélien a été blessé par l'explosion
perpétrés par des inconnus contre un
barrage de l'armée israélienne quatre
personnes ont été arrêtées
gérard ce vague au bord de la mer à
quelques kilomètres de beyrouth le beach
hotel est sans doute le seul lieu du
liban où la diplomatie l'emportent sur
la guerre folle en neuvième rendez-vous
libanais et israéliens et américains
étaient quand même un peu plus tendue
que d'habitude
la séance a été interrompue par un tir
de mortier
un obus qui devait viser l'hôtel est
tombé à 400 mètres sur une position
israélienne les soldats israéliens ont
aussitôt lancé une opération pour
repérer les tireurs mais leur action a
été interrompue l'obus était tirée d'une
zone contrôlée par l'armée américaine
affirme tel aviv
là où les soldats israéliens n'ont pas
le droit de pénétrer dans la salle des
séances
les délégués ont poursuivi leurs
négociations des négociations menées
avec décontraction même si les progrès
sont minimes fort appréciée comme on le
voit par les délégués israéliens les
pistaches nous sommes en orient et on
parle en mangeant mais il faut savoir
que la majorité des pistaches rendu au
liban sont à portée de ciron c'est dire
la complexité des négociations au cours
de cette 9ème séance le point délicat
abordé était celui de l'importation de
stations dallaire israélienne au libre
au même moment face au parlement
israélien aujourd'hui premier ministre
menahem menahem begin réaffirme l
intransigeance de sa position dans ces
négociations
surtout en ce qui concerne une présence
israélienne dans les stations de
contrôle électronique que les états unis
veulent s'installer au sud liban après
avoir reçu hier le négociateur américain
philip a bible monsieur begin s'est dit
optimiste quant à la volonté des syriens
de quitter le liban
mais la position de l'ol paie en la
matière par est plus indécise dans une
interview à notre correspondant au caire
pierre serra le président de l'ol paie
yasser arafat vient de ré affirmé de son
côté la fermeté palestinienne écoutons
le
vaincu militairement à beyrouth
contestée souvent au sein de l'ol paie
yasser arafat est il un homme seul comme
ici dans son bureau des environs de
tunis où le leader du lp travail sous la
photo des mosquées de jérusalem donne
des instructions et où pour répondre à
nos questions à pistolet aux côtés il a
juste avec soin
le caissier qui a été le symbole de la
résistance palestinienne est sous le cas
il apparaît toujours devant la
télévision mais quelle est aujourd'hui
la situation politique de noël et vous
pensez que les négociations israélo
libanaise chaldée en territoire
israélien avait abouti au nom de
monsieur shamir a dit que l'ol paie doit
partir d'abord capital israélien
partiront alors jamais
bon ben alors et la reconnaissance
mutuelle israël aux palestiniens laissez
moi vous poser la question mais
israélien vous connaissent toutes façons
vous les connaissez ou lorsque ceux-ci
de nardis l'âme des victimes a déclaré
zahra vous ou plutôt je suis tombé à
beyrouth sa mauvaise butternut motivé
promesses tôt en basque de sapiens
invoqué un ddt de cycle des thèses
changeant de registre
il a 26 ans il est beau il est riche et
il veut enfin profiter de la vie et de
la fortune qu'il a amassée dans le tamis
de sa raquette
bjorn borg c'est officiel se retire de
la compétition en disant six victoires à
roland garros 5 à wimbledon une coupe
davis de master björn borg a régné en
demi dieu sur les kouriles a bouleversé
le tennis mondial
son portrait et côté cour et côté jardin
en jézabel ilie nastase disait de lui
lorsqu'il était à son meilleur niveau ce
n'est pas un joueur de tennis est un
extraterrestre le seul moyen de venir à
bout de cette espèce de
c'est de la battre après avoir gagné
effectivement six fois roland garros
cinq fois à wimbledon une coupe davis
deux masters the big board décide au
début de l'année dernière de prendre du
recul depuis l'âge de 16 ans sa vie se
résume en trois mots tennis dollars dodo
il prend huit mois de vacances puis
revient à la compétition à monte carlo
où il est battu par noah borg se
consacre ensuite aux exhibitions et fin
1982 au mois de décembre à anvers c'est
le deuxième retour du champion quel
conseil pourrait lui donner pour eux
ah oui cet égard sont fait l'écho il
essaie de se battre qu'il joue son
meilleur tennis n'attendent pas trop de
lui même s'il ne met pas trop de
pression sur l'hymne et puis tu verras
petit gars les choses iront très bien
mais tout ne va pas si bien sur le court
borg a bien retrouver sa condition
physique sa technique mais il est devenu
incapable de
non
nouvelle interruption pardonnez-nous
elle est commune aux trois chaînes nous
sommes maintenant repasser de
l'alimentation en électricité du groupe
au secteur alors nous allons retrouver
bien de borg gun board d'orange et sa
belle donc nous fait le portrait à
l'occasion de son retrait officiel de la
compétition
ranger zabel maintenant j'ai la chance
de faire des choses différentes et ça
c'est bon j'ai moins de pression sur moi
maintenant s'il ya quelques années je
ressentais de la pression sur le court
de tennis
en dehors du court partout où j'allais y
avait la pression la pression
aujourd'hui je suis beaucoup plus
décontractée c'est une sensation
merveilleuse et je n'avais pas ressenti
ça depuis cinq ou six ans c'est dû au
repos que j'ai pris je pense en fait je
suis bien et pourtant il était si bien
sur ce court où il a mis fin au tennis
académique pour créer le tennis efficace
que tant de jeunes tentent d'imiter borg
a gagné 2 milliards et demi de centimes
en compétition officielle
entre 1973 et 1980 sans compter bien sûr
tous ces contrats d'équipement et de
publicité et dans ce match entre le
champion bord et l'homme borg
c'est l'homme qui l'a finalement emporté
quoi
rapidement le temps alain gillot-pétré
le temps demain et bien le temps demain
c'est assez simple sur le sud-est du
pays comme vous le voyez ici ce sera du
beau temps avec toujours quelques
brouillards givrants sur la la franche
comté et le lyonnais sur le nord-ouest
du pays davantage de nuages ce sont les
nuages qui sont à nos portes et qui nous
apporterons quelques pluies
j'ajoute qu'il ya des problèmes de
télévision des interférences sur le sud
ouest et les vosges juste à cause du
temps c'est pas de la faute des autres
les températures quand elles sont en
hausse pour demain minimum 5 degrés dans
le nord-est maximum 17 degrés à biarritz
je ne vous donne pas les fumées riggi
par la rai de lumière et ce n'est pas
vraiment pas le moment christine alors
je vous redonne lac
22h50 claude sérillon vous présentera
notre dernier journal et vous pourrez y
voir in extenso lankais d'alain doublé
ce qui sur le rappel de certains modèles
de la régie renault
le reportage vous en souvenez avait été
interrompue par une malencontreuse panne
d'électricité voilà j'aurai le plaisir
de vous retrouver demain à 20 heures
bonne soirée sur antenne 2